Звідси до Румунії - рукою подати.
Але більшість українських чоловіків не можуть перейти цей кордон. Принаймні законно.
Через воєнний стан чоловіки призовного віку повинні залишатися в країні.
Підроблені документи - один із способів порушити цю заборону.
Ще один шлях - через густі ліси та гірські перевали.
Понад 15 000 людей було затримано в Україні під час спроби нелегально потрапити до Румунії.
Ці прикордонники намагаються їх зупинити.
Сьогодні ввечері Володимир та Василь відповідають за охорону 12-кілометрової смуги.
Щоб забезпечити дотримання закону і, можливо, врятувати чиєсь життя.
Тут рівнини, болотиста місцевість.
Дійсно, можуть і заблудитися.
Дикі звірі - ведмідь проживає в нас. Можуть натрапити на ведмедя.
Нам повідомили, що з початку повномасштабного російського вторгнення
у південному прикордонному регіоні України було виявлено два десятки тіл.
Раніше цей маршрут був популярним серед контрабандистів сигарет,
але зараз ним переважно користуються люди, які намагаються залишити країну.
Ухилянти, біженці, контрабандисти… Військовий стан.
Вони бояться. Що ми їх затримаємо, оформимо по 204-ій статті, їх оштрафують і заберуть у військкомат.
204 стаття передбачає адміністративний штраф за незаконний перетин кордону - до 8500 гривень.
За спробу виїзду з підробними документами - штраф або позбавлення волі.
Покарання у вигляді поїздки у військкомат не передбачено законом.
Але може бути негласною домовленістю військових і прикордонників.
А далі - перспектива, що лякає багатьох - опинитися на фронті.
Адже Україні потрібні солдати.
У Чернівцях, неподалік румунського кордону, їх намагаються мотивувати ось такими оголошеннями.
На початку війни сотні тисяч людей пішли служити добровільно.
Через півтора року багато хто з них виснажений, поранений або... загинув.
Більшість українців підтримують і довіряють ЗСУ. Але служити готові не всі.
Згідно із соцопитуванням, проведеним улітку цьогоріч,
найперші ознаки патріотизму, на думку українців, - донати й волонтерство, а також спілкування українською.
Служба в армії - на третьому місці.
На військову службу можуть бути призвані чоловіки віком від 18 до 60 років. Але є винятки.
Наприклад, батьки трьох і більше дітей, опікуни хворих батьків, незамінні працівники підприємств.
А ще - звільнення від служби за медичними довідками.
Саме так більшість людей ухиляється від призову.
Тисячі чоловіків змогли виїхати за кордон, підкупивши чиновників.
Злочинні групи, що заробляють на цьому, рекламують свої послуги в Telegram.
Наприклад, оформлення інвалідності може коштувати до трьох з половиною тисяч доларів.
Це можливо лише за допомогою чиновників і співробітників військкоматів.
У серпні було звільнено керівників усіх обласних ТЦК -
у рамках більш масштабних заходів щодо боротьби з корупцією в оборонному секторі.
Ми не можемо сказати, що це була тотальна корупція.
Це були досить поодинокі випадки.
Ми одразу кажемо, що ми маємо нульову терпимість до випадків корупції та інших порушень.
Звичайно, є людський фактор, але ми намагаємося реагувати на будь-які проблеми.
Але деякі українські чоловіки замислюються, чому вони мають служити.
І шукають способи уникнути призову.
Максим - один із них.
22-річний майстер тату каже, що підтримує ЗСУ, але сам не хоче воювати.
Я вважаю, що власна країна - це цінніше, ніж бути біженцем десь.
Але ціна, яку просять заплатити за власну країну - каліцтво чи смерть - для мене набагато вища, ніж ця цінність.
Я краще став би біженцем, аніж помру. Але не факт, що тут буде країна після того, як ти помреш.
Питаємо Максима, як він ставиться до співвітчизників-українців,
які змушені жити під російською окупацією і сподіваються на визволення.
Максимум, за кого я пішов би воювати, - це моє близьке оточення, ті люди, яких я вважаю своєю спільнотою.
Люди, наприклад, з Луганська - я не сказав би, що це моя спільнота. Я їх не знаю і ніколи не бачив.
І вони мене не знають і ніколи не бачили.
Насправді, для мене вони не існують. І я для них не існую.
Це дуже дивна ідея - воювати за людей, котрих я навіть ніколи не бачив.
Цих чоловіків нещодавно мобілізували.
Вони - новобранці Національної гвардії.
Серед них і Михайло - вантажник у цивільному житті.
Він отримав повістку чотири місяці тому.
Я спочатку був… І зараз я обмежено придатний за станом здоров'я. У мене ось немає…
Я зрозумів, що… Ну, куди діватися? Бачите, зараз на кожному кроці запрошують, скажемо так.
Після кількох тижнів тренувань Михайло, як і решта новобранців, складає присягу.
Чоловік не береться засуджувати тих, хто ухиляється від служби, але їхню позицію не поділяє.
Я розумію, що зараз я не в такому стані, що можу одразу піти на передову.
Але ми всі по мірі своїх можливостей повинні нести якусь службу.
Навіть у тилових частинах потрібні якісь працівники.
Я усім раджу не ховатися, не тікати. Вас одразу не цей…
Пройдете перевірку і так далі. Навіть як я - обмежено придатний - мені знайдеться робота тут.
На кордоні з Румунією Володимир та Василь поки не виявили слідів незаконних переходів.
Утім, лише напередодні нашої зйомки на цій ділянці кордону
затримали трьох чоловіків призовного віку, які намагалися перелізти через колючий дріт.
За оперативною інформацією наших працівників, особа, яка проживає в цій області, намагається їх переводити.
Ми цю особу визначили і швидше, ніж вони, дійшли до місця, де вони хотіли вчинити правопорушення.
Намагалися перетнути державний кордон незаконно, використовуючи певні для цього приладдя.
Стосовно саморобних дерев'яних сходів, щось на зразок такого,
вони їх накидають на лінію інженерних споруд і завдяки їм можуть її перейти.
Тільки в серпні прикордонники запобігли 247 випадкам перетину кордону. Насправді ж їх набагато більше.
Кожен має свою думку. Я сам воював, знаю, як там було.
Нікому не бажав би там бути. Там нелегко.
У кого яка доля. Кожен свої ухвалює рішення.
Володимир каже, що не може судити тих, хто тікає. Але, як і сотні тисяч українців, що воюють на фронті,
прикордонники теж мають обов'язок, і вони сповнені рішучості його виконувати.